can you tell us about the 25 year old
American filmmaker who saw awaken fright
in 1971 well I went to the cat Film
Festival and the day my film was
screened I was in competition for the
Palme d'Or and I set as a special seat
for the director right in the very front
of the balcony and the jury came in we
bowed to each other and the film started
there's boys behind me in in American
which was unusual because most people
have said there would be Europeans it's
okay
and the voice skips think wow wow what a
scene why this director is great this is
great of course music - the directors
ears to hear all this approbation right
I didn't mind I'd seen the film six
other times wasn't distracting me and
anyway and the climax of the film which
is I don't like should give away I
wonder what the climax is but it's it's
a rape scene right and he says Wow
just a wrecker he's gonna go all the way
he's going he's going all the way oh my
god it's so great president he went all
the way so that was towards the end the
lights go up I look back and I see this
25 year old young man I wasn't much that
much older when I made the film I was in
my thirties and but I went outside and
the you a PR public publicity guy they
said there's somebody sitting behind me
do you know who he was
no he's American no I said then suddenly
he just came out of the movie how does
that mean what are you coming out late I
said that's him they said uh yeah yeah
yeah he's a young American directing
only made one film that flopped he said
it'd be no interest to you two I said
well I like to know his name you should
what would make wouldn't be didn't think
you would wanna know was named for just
give me his name
so the other thing I said I remember it
was Martin Scorsese I said you're right
never know but name is stuck in my head
right and I I found out what his name
was
we've got my email and thank him for all
his comments behind me 38 years later we
made this great print after the film has
been lost and buried it rises from the
grave and the spread can ask for the
picture the ask for this new print to be
sent to Ken and it was sent to him sent
to them in in France and they declared
it the can classic and screened it again
guess who is head of the Ken classics
department after 38 years you remembered
my film it was of course Martin Scorsese
as one of the most amazing things has
ever happened to me in it
I always treasured that moment and what
he remembered my film after he could and
Martin Scorsese has an encyclopedic
knowledge of films he's seen thousands
of films and you remembered my film I
mean it was extraordinary and so but
very funny I I'd never met him
I always thought wrote him again thanked
him for I hope you won't think it's to
boast II to say the only two films I've
heard good screen twice at the Cannes
Film Festival one was Michelangelo
Antonioni's Levin sure I had my film
make it right
any rates uh two years ago there was a
at Oscar time there are Oscar parties
and I'm always been invited I go to sign
I don't let go much your Oscar parties
but but in this case it was a director
friend of mine and so I went and I see
Martin Scorsese and De Niro sitting
together it was at the Beverly Hills
Hotel so I went over and said we've
never met a mr. Scorsese I'm Ted couch
mom it's not a great film I've seen your
films your dragon and then I told the
Niro said you know I told him what this
story the vigil Jew about talking all
through my film in in Ken in 1971 he
said he does that to everybody still but
you know he's such a big supporter of
the film to this day these distributors
Drafthouse went phoned him up said we're
making a new poster would you give us a
quote and he gave them a quote to use
when the poster which is being used
I mean that that man is not only
perceptive but generous
you